and the magnus will have the white
pieces in the next game
oh down to three seconds
really keeping us on edge and what's he
doing he's just giving up a pawn
is this necessary
it's he's showing off now
i mean
it might still be a draw but why go for
this it makes no sense
chances for magnus now yeah definitely
it's just you don't need to give up a
pawn like this yeah incredible i mean it
was just completely level i mean this is
yeah i mean this is kind of plain magnus
and you're like i'm just going to give
myself some pain because
yeah
i i don't understand that at all just
parking your king on the op and in a
corner square on the opposite collar to
your opponent's bishop is enough to draw
so there is still some leeway despite
what the computer says right now artemis
should still draw this game just by
planting the white king in the corner of
the board uh later on if he needs to
that's why magnus keeps the knights on
the board how about the clock time is it
hard for artemiv to do that with so
little time on the clock well now the
knights are on the board i think it's
going to be a difficult task for him you
know he's more than capable of holding
this position but he has made a bit of a
mountain out of a molehill in this
defense i mean you can re-route this
knight to attack the h-pawn um and the
bishop can attack the h pawns so black
can potentially get both of his pieces
attacking white's remaining pawn and
that could really tie down uh white and
the other thing is you can play this
position on forever now and before you
never give your opponent a pawn for free
in an ending even if it is a draw just
just uh just torturing yourself
any other opponent in the world artemis
would have just played that end game he
was about to fizzle out to a draw he
wouldn't have cared but then he just
wanted to force it he wanted to force
the draw immediately but he gave up a
pawn in the process body language is
still pretty relaxed but if he smells
blood if he sees the game continue uh to
move in black's favor the momentum on
his side then
we could well be seeing another 50 moves
of torture it's porn as well and um
i i could certainly see uh white losing
this this one actually yeah um it's it's
unpleasant and uh what about if the
bishops get traded off because uh magnus
now has a possibility of doing he hasn't
done it i think yeah you can take the
bishops off the board at any moment
later in the game anyway so there's no
need to rush the black knight is going
towards this white corner pawn
and there we go a big threat against
white's remaining pawn it's isolated
it's weak if you defend it with the
white knight now the black king comes in
oh this one is hanging by a thread for
i'll tell you incredibly scary yeah and
magnus has got three minutes to enjoy
his position
uh i'll tell me seconds compared the
kings white's king is paralyzed stuck
defending the pawn in front of it
black's king has a free run it's going
to dislodge the white knight first and
then the black king is going to move
over slowly towards the white king going
to try and trap it on the edge of the
two seconds one second wow oh with one
second left on the clock oh
brinksmanship
oh i've okay and black's king could have
attacked both pieces at the same time
there but white king could have defended
them i'm really wondering what artemis
missed to give up
but no down to three seconds four
seconds again black's king is coming in
this is really uncomfortable now for for
uh for whites he's getting uh pushed
around all over shop and white's pieces
and such bad squares
it's still not easy for magnus to find
the killer blow he's black's pieces are
all on perfect squares but white has set
up a defensive fortress in a way so okay
he brings his bishop in black cutting
off all the squares
how many times have you seen magnus win
positions like this so it's so many i've
seen i've seen it do it so many times
where everyone thinks it's a draw and
all of a sudden he will just play
against two seconds one second is he
lost at all he did it with two seconds
left like knight e to get the bishop
hitting h2 knight g1 checkmate is is one
very powerful idea i mean the white king
don't go for the h-bomb go for checkmate
here why not knight e2 looks incredibly
dangerous yeah exactly white's king
lacking squares if the knight goes back
slightly surprising that one
uh as you mentioned simon that was so
tempting at least threatened the idea of
checkmate and
uh okay instead
now white's knight has centralized so
maybe slightly uh better set up
defensively you've got still the same
idea in the air you know the white king
doesn't have too many squares and uh
artemia is just reduced to moving his
knight to random squares yep and if he
just checks the king with the black
knight is checkmate now so okay it takes
a while to get there but if you can do
that whilst white can't improve his
position um is checkmate so you know
just pick up the black knight and yes on
f2 or g1 checkmate but maybe this is a
bad circuit actually for the white
knight
knight might get trapped by the black
bishop black bishop could just take a
step back maybe
but i'm also thinking in terms of checks
okay it's not that easy for black he's
going for it he gets actually yeah the
knight
the knight is just trying to get into
position where it checks the white king
and that is checkmate so okay so he
probably he has to move the bishop right
yeah
bishop jumping out the way so the white
knight can occupy the square it
previously stood on with a check you
need to kick away the black king the
black king has completely boxed in its
counterpart its rival there still so
calm isn't he artem
i just cool but okay look okay we have
checkmate in the air it's a fret knight
g1 okay
one yeah there's only two ways to stop
that either you give a check to the
black king or you bring the white bishop
back to cover any potential checking
squares from the black knight two
seconds only two possible moves to stop
checkmate
he gives a check himself unbelievable i
can't believe he looks so calm
i i know what i would be doing here and
he wouldn't be looking like that i mean
he'd be dripping sweat on the floor
and again he's making the move with
three seconds to spare i'm just going to
check as well while the game continues
while white knight hits the black bishop
i'm going to check how many moves he
needs to survive to make the 50 move
okay
now there's an exchange of pieces
possibly but is choice for artemia does
he rock the boat
and uh make the trade or does he kind of
maintain the same situation and he's
just chosen to maintain the same peace
formation so it's gonna be knight and
bishop because knight and bishop and he
steps back with his king but
maybe missing an opportunity there yeah
black needs to keep the night alive to
win the game but in that type of
position it's a fine line right between
a draw and a loss artemis just didn't
have enough time to calculate whether
trading a night for the black bishop was
beneficial for him so we continue we're
going to go round in a bit of a circle
here the last pawn move was on move 44.
so they've made 24 moves okay halfway
yeah 24 moves without a capture and
without a pawn push if it's 50 moves so
if there's no capture or pawn push
before uh black's 94th move it's a draw
okay the i mean it's more stressful now
i can't my nerves aren't the same as
they used to be okay we see a trade so
no more 50 move rule
but yeah i was just going to say it's
become more of a habit now a bad habit
that i need to kick
time travel is definitely a sin
at home and you simon do you i mean when
i'm in this kind of situation with
seconds left on the clock i feel
incredibly stressed do you feel i i i
can't handle it i mean i i just
you know i've got enough bad habits as
it is i don't need any more
so you know
but i i love the rush i mean i love
blitz chess over the board and i do you
know the agenda in is is incredible yeah
but um i i don't play very well when i'm
short of time i'm not particularly good
at calculating quickly like david is oh
hang on a second
okay the bishops have come off so black
meets his knight hang a bit
okay oh no
no matter what what does now his
position will worsen if the white king
moves the black king comes across and
takes the white pawn if the white knight
moves the white knight is getting
trapped
sneaky
incredible incredible i mean i thought
the piece is exchanged off that's nearer
to a draw next move losing
the same and
here you can't you can't guard your h
pawn in the long run so i i think
another pawn is going to drop here isn't
it yeah you have to be a bit careful as
black white's knight does threaten maybe
to jump into the centre of the board
with a check that's why black covers any
potential checks white's knight is
completely frozen white tonight has to
stay on that square to defend its
remaining pawn and then the black knight
there we go this is the one yeah you
have to stop white's knight uh jumping
into that square i guess then and with
one second on the clock again of course
yeah
wow i think you're right he had this
against uh the young russian yeah that's
right alex senko alexenko alexenko that
was a niche gary very similar at least
yeah okay black's knight is coming it
started its journey towards that white
pawn and oh down to four seconds three
seconds two
okay he made it with a few seconds left
and uh now the black knight needs to
find
a route towards that point the one
problem with knights is they don't they
can't lose time they're incapable of
losing tempe so you have to get a
position where white is completely
frozen but you need to move your knight
round to the right square at the right
time when your opponent's pieces are on
the right squares it's still tricky for
magnus to do this
to work out
okay now
no he's covered that square
the white king will have to just wait
the white knight if it moves the pawn
drops the white king has to just
sidestep
wow so he has to make his move no other
move you have to bring your king across
there we go he plays it and now black's
king ah is this just
genius by magnus has he found the zuswan
now the white knight's still stuck if
the white king moves away the blacking
goes towards the white knight it's
incredible to watch i mean it's
incredible to watch just just the
understanding yeah and you can see now
white's king is being pushed further and
further away anna but he had to get his
knight to the square yeah exactly i was
going to say put this position in your
memory banks you know especially the
technique that he used you know just
improving the placing of his knight to
control the squares of the white king i
must admit this is all fantastic
technique i think he can win the pawn
immediately by giving a check and then
retreating the black knight to attack
this white pawn white's pawn is about to
fall it's going to be two pawns against
none and it still might take a while but
that is a winning end game
yeah hits check oh we played it with one
second
again incredible and now the black
knight can step back attacking this
white pawn that pawn is falling and it's
important that the black knight once it
captures that white pawn will defend its
own pawns
and if magnus does win this game then he
only needs a draw in game three to be
ready for the final ladies love our
tempo he will have to win both of the
two last rapid games to take it to tie
breaks
yeah he's enjoying himself a bit too
much over that move i feel yeah and he's
uh he's going for the more beautiful
zugswang
and it it's one thing that amazes me
about chess and i love about chess is
you can have brilliant brilliancies with
all the pieces on the board smashing
attacks which are really visually
beautiful but then you can have these
kind of games where there's only a
couple of pieces on the board and
they're just as beautiful but completely
different so there's so much beauty and
chess in so many different ways and now
he's two pawns up he can uh he can just
slowly roll those pawns down the board
which which he he's going to do now and
he's going to do it with the assistance
of the whole team because the one danger
there is for black is that the white
knight and can swap itself off for two
pawns and that's if that's the case then
it's going to be a draw but of course
black can easily stop this yep you have
to keep one pawn alive you can't let the
white knight get both of them
and uh there we go the white king
planting itself in front of the black
pawns you just have to do this step by
step uh for magnus i would get my king
out of the way soon over the next few
moves i don't really want the black king
in the way of the pawns ideally
but magnus has a lot of time on the
clock nearly three minutes and no 50
move rule we should mention in this one
because that will reset every time black
pushes a pawn and he does that
immediately okay so um i guess it's okay
having it's it's fine here having the
king in front of black's pawns because
white's knight and king again they will
be stuck at some point they will have to
give way
and yeah it's just a matter of time
right yeah i think yeah i mean he's he's
done you you never relax so this is this
is a big mistake i've made because chess
is is such a stressful game i mean uh i
think arya said it's like do an exam you
know like an exam you get very stressed
out and it's really hard work on the
mind and as soon as you drop your guard
it's bang you you throw away all that
hard work so only relax when the game's
over and it's so easy to think oh i've
won this now i don't just go into
autopilot biggest mistake you can make
that is going into autopilot mode you
need to have that endurance to finish
things off yeah i saw some stats
actually that most car accidents happen
within two miles of uh reaching your
destination and it's the same with chess
most blunders happen just when you're on
the brink of winning or just on the
brink of making a draw so uh it's yeah
it's just that phenomenon of relaxing
too early wow that's interesting um so
okay meanwhile white's just waiting
nothing else to do with the king black
has relocated his knight
he's ready is it now or over the next
few moves to push a pawn
and magnus just calculating the risk he
just wants to make sure that there are
no stalemates for example um or any
night sacrifices by white or any
annoying checks
all right so game three between yana
pomnyacci and andreas penco that has
started napoleon she won game two and is
up by one point if he wins game three
going on right now he will be ready for
the finals asapenko needs at least a
draw and he also needs to win either
this game or game four to take it to tie
breaks we will jump straight into that
game as soon as this is finished can it
still last for some time this one still
might go for a while i think we will hit
the move 100 mark that i get so excited
yeah i mean i'll tell you if he's doing
the right thing he's not resigning we
saw in his body language a few minutes a
few months ago that he's pretty much
given up he knows he's losing
objectively but as we see by magnus
thinking now it's not easy there are
still some tricks left and this is what
i recommend everyone at home never
resign especially in engines like this
there's always resources or always
tricks
that you can set for your opponent to
save the game the number of times when i
was young or especially even now when i
play online in blitz you pre-move or
something and stalemate and the game is
over
and our
statsposs asking just messaged me saying
that this is good for magnus's fighting
chess as statistics that we do know he
wants to have a high score on the
fighting chess index and
a hundred moves that's gonna be good for
the index yeah exactly especially if he
ends up winning decisive game yeah yeah
so you must have a massive fighting
index with your 200 200 300 move games
or whatever you love doing on a regular
basis it's like
i remember uh dave smurden uh released
stats for i think it was the top hundred
players in the world and i wasn't that
high i was a bit surprised i was a bit
annoyed about that but um
so you're not you're not a fighting
player though i mean
maybe he put the wrong games in maybe he
is
again i remember one story where you're
playing at the british championships and
you're playing gary lane in the last
round and david only needs a draw to win
the british championships outright and
that is a big title is something i'd
love to have myself and uh i know ivanka
has won the british ladies championships
many times um but gary offered david a
draw quite quickly
and everyone thought of course you take
the draw you become british champion you
hit the bar hard and uh dave was like no
i just beat him instead
he was just like david did you beat him
okay right okay but you're still gonna
save myself a few hours if i die
you
you said no you could become british
champion now and you're like you decided
i was like wow this is incredible so i
was young i was full of optimism
meanwhile there have been some moves we
should mention black is actually giving
up his night magnus is letting white
take the black knight but that would
distract the white king and the black
pawns are just going to run through and
promote and we see in the evaluation bar
it's completely winning for black now
magnus just needs to choose the right
square phase king
i'm not sure whether it matters i mean i
would go in front of my pawn here to be
honest but uh yeah i think this one is
winning the black pawns are just too
close to the promotion squares now
yeah i would definitely go in front of
my pawn it looks good and let harry
take the glory harry will become a queen
queen harriet harris and uh yeah
actually
this is instructive because knight
struggled most against those flanker
pawns knight's struggle against harry
and alice
the most so promote harry here that's
the key harry
harry and harry well will we see uh
harriet the queen or will our time have
give up before that do you think
he'll give up before then i think it'd
be when it becomes apparent that he
can't uh
maintain well you know he will tell me
if he's trying
but uh
simply you can't take the pawn that's
the problem the knight takes pawn you
just give a check with your knight and
king h4 i mean you still have to
calculate that i mean doing it the hard
way he's still working things out right
yeah i mean i i would be like okay this
this looks like
still uh you know you've only got one
pawn now and it's like right you have to
be very careful about your calculation
here i mean um
i i'm surprised by this actually i think
magnus is going for something that he's
studied before i've seen this end game
with uh a king and a pawn on this square
and white's knight completely stuck
stopping the black pawn and all you need
to do is black is relocate your knight
distract the white knight and then your
pawn promotes to a queen so i think
magnus
had it worked out pretty much or has
seen something very similar to this
before seen this pattern yeah it's
incredible again how he just finishes
the game off you know even here it's
like wow he knows this is a win and he's
got it he's got zugswang six swag no
matter what white does you will lose the
white knight it's game over and artemiev
i think has just resigned so impressive
he's so